[Music]
thank you
erdogan is facing the challenge of his
political career this Sunday as turkey
goes to the polls
edgy Tamil current in this week's
magazine says that it's the final
countdown for democracy in the country
she joins me now along with Hannah
Lucinda Smith
actually in this week's magazine you
write for the upcoming elections in
turkey and you're explaining to a
western audience how we should
understand the political scene and you
use an example involving brexit and
Trump can you talk us through this
not sure I mean like we all those people
who come from complicated non-western
countries we have to simplify things for
the Western audience to have an access
to our Madness so to speak so yeah I'm
using that you know imagine 20 years of
brexit pending or imagine a trump with
political genius and Islamic aspirations
recently we had to do it for the
earthquake as well uh to explain the you
know the the scale of the impact we were
saying that it's one Austria or two
swedens and so on so this is what we do
I mean like we're trying to break down
our
extremely complex Insanity for the
Western audiences and this was all the
only way to explain how Turkish people
feel after 20 years of erdogan I think
Hannah could you give us a summary of
the election campaigns so far
yeah so I mean it got off to a quite a
slow start
um yeah at the beginning when
campaigning started in late March
um the government said you know out of
respect for the earthquake victims we're
going to keep it located there's going
to be no music there's not really going
to be you know what you usually have in
a Turkish election campaign which is you
know election Vans driving around and
every Public Square you have you the
parties setting out their stalls and
playing music
yeah they said at the start this time
around it's going to be very low-key and
it was until the end of Ramadan
um the end of April and then since then
it's really
really you know got into gear and I
think particularly since you know
erdogan and his team have realized that
they are in danger of losing that
there's a possibility that they could
lose this one
um you know kilish derolu has never
looked like a particularly hopeful
candidate in the past and I think when
he was announced
um as the presidential candidate back in
March probably the government and and
erdogan you know kind of thought oh
brilliant well would definitely beat him
and Against All Odds kalistarillo has
actually managed to kind of hold a
really diverse and quite fragile
Coalition together
um and I think you know particularly in
the past week
we've seen uh not only the campaigning
increase yeah both killister Olu and
erdogan held massive rallies in Istanbul
at the weekend they've been both touring
the country all over the place but also
we've seen a kind of escalation of the
rhetoric we've seen erdogan you know
increasing this kind of really divisive
really caustic rhetoric and you know at
the same time as promising all kinds of
things and talking about all the things
that he's done in 20 years in power
we've seen him going for LGBT
communities we've seen him going for
college over his alivism over his faith
um yeah we've seen a classic go to
Antarctic him talking about you know
people who give votes to the opposition
as terrorists so he's really turning to
all these kind of fault lines that he's
exploited in the past
um and have worked for him in the past
now the question is are they going to
work for him this time that that's the
key question
you know that's true I mean yeah we are
well I am wishing that it won't but then
I can see that it is working for his
Fanatics as we spoke earlier before the
program Hannah I mean like it is
incredible and it is not easy to explain
uh especially to Western audience why
there are still people who are
supporting I don't want like there is no
tomorrow and we all know that like you
know they cannot be convinced otherwise
even if you come with the most concrete
uh you know if evidence that proves that
he's a yeah he's a fraud
and actually on on that I mean you write
in your piece about the final countdown
for Turkey
um can you talk us through what is that
stake here really for the country I mean
we're erdogan to win again what does
that mean
well um to begin with I mean like this
is two decades-long rule out on and the
first term was a little bit Milder
uh less eventful let's say but then
after this he got he won the power for
the second time uh he kind of Unleashed
uh his aspiration for power holding on
to power forever
and especially after 2013 gezia pricing
um it became clear uh that there will be
suppression uh and you know those who do
not obey erdogan's regime will be
labeled as terrorists which has been the
case since last 10 years now
and then after 2016 the coup attempt uh
everything got really blurry the
equivalent has been used as an excuse by
erdogan to suppress the entire country
all his critics and I don't you know
there are thousands of people in prison
and tens of thousands have left Turkey
right after the coup because it became
clear that they will not be able to live
as first-class citizens
um and now there's the economic crisis
so
I don't is very clear through his
propaganda machine through his own
statements
that he's going to be ruling the country
as a you know political Asylum so to
speak
uh recently like I think it was
yesterday his interior Minister now a MP
candidate
a very important political figure in
this uh you know campaign said that they
have been stomping on us referring to
the opposition and he said we are going
to be stomping all over them after the
election which is an open threat and if
you live in Turkey you know that this
means violence this means uh all out uh
you know oppression so you know Western
audiences do not do not like me using
this word but it is fascism and it will
be fully formed uh fascism after if I go
on wins this election
Hannah do you think that's fair I I
agree with that yeah I agree I mean I
think
you know clearly erdogan is
um he's an islamist of course
um but I think that there is far too
much focus on that part of what he is if
we really examine what's going on here
it's fascism I mean look at the kind of
um the definition everything in service
of the state the leader becomes
Inseparable from the state and
Inseparable from the nation so and then
you know that system wants to control
everything it wants to control art it
wants to control music culture
discussion media uh business everything
okay this is a definition of fascism and
this is what's happened in Turkey
um and I think you know we really can't
overstay if erdogan wins again and wins
another five years there is going to be
nothing left to democracy in this
country if we look at what he's done
since 2018
um yeah after the last elections so in
those elections triggered a new
constitution constitution in which
erdogan is executive president in which
basically he the kind of the state is
almost kind of arranged around him like
the Sun King everything comes from him
you know the ministry is no longer
really have any autonomy
State institutions don't the courts are
full of his loyalists the Electoral
board is full of his loyalists the
security forces have been purged we
don't know really what's going on in
security forces and how loyal they are
to him give him another five years there
is going to be nothing left of the
democratic checks and balances in this
country even now really the only kind of
balance that is left is elections it's
his only Achilles heel is the fact that
he still has to go to The Ballot Box
because that's the way he came in and
that's the rhetoric he relies on you
know when you listen to erdogan talk
it's all about the will of the people
about democratization
Etc so he still relies on the ballot box
but pretty much there's almost nothing
else left in terms of democratic checks
and balances
and those elections are frequently
overshadowed like shadowed by the
election fraud massive election fraud
and
um world theft which has become so
natural that the opposition party is
giving you know seminars and briefings
about how they're going to protect the
votes from the world theft of the
government this is like insanity uh you
know on one side there is a man and his
propaganda machine going towards a war
as if and you know the opposition is
still trying to you know use the
Democratic means I think this is you
know this the importance of this
election goes Far Beyond turkey because
you know all those countries who have
been subjected to Rising
authoritarianism I have to learn uh well
if kalistarolo if the opposition wins
turkey will be showing the entire world
that you know you can get rid of
authoritarian fascist leader through
Democratic means despite the fact that
he ruined every institution in the
country and not only the institutions to
be honest it's the moral demise of a
country
uh Hana would be very familiar with this
you know there are videos of AKP
supporters that are quite popular on
social media and they're showing uh I
don't want devotees rather saying we uh
you know we we are going to vote for
erdogan because he gave us the chance to
beat up the doctors if we do not like
them and they see this as uh like you
know their uh I don't know they see this
their their rightful response uh to an
oppressive Elite which is now you know
which Western world is not quite
familiar with uh that term so
um it's not only going to be fascism but
also it's going to be this
um
well I cannot not use strong words it's
going to be vandalism
uh prevailing over you know basic moral
values of a country
and just on the Fallout from the result
I wondered do you think that whatever
the result is it will be accepted
yeah
what do you think Anna
foreign
listen erdogan has form I mean in 2019
in the local elections in Istanbul the
opposition won by a superfine margin
um it was first time in 25 years that
erdogan's party had not won an Istanbul
Istanbul is his home City it's his power
base it was like and he turned it into a
referendum on himself as well so it's
like a personal insult to him and uh he
leaned on the Electoral board to
overrule it
um now in the end what happened you know
Imam Olu the opposition uh candidate
he's got a really really smart team
around them they really went for
intentionally hitting the streets and
doing whatever they could and he won
again
um but you know I think you know whether
you see this as like a hopeful sign or
um you know uh kind of warning depends
on whether you're an optimistic person
or not some people say well oh look you
know in the end democracy one personally
for me I think you know this shows that
he's totally willing to use the
institutions to overrule results he
doesn't like and I think you know this
is national elections this isn't just
Istanbul we're what four years on from
that he's gathered even more Powers you
know back in 2019 the Constitutional
Court was still somewhat independent
like now not at all
um and I think you know it comes down to
a numbers game I think if the opposition
can win it by a really clear margin and
I'm talking sort of 10 percent
then it would be very very difficult I
think for you know erdogan to lean on uh
on the bureaucracy and on state
apparatus as he did in 2019. on the
other hand if it's two percent three
percent which is what it's looking like
at the moment I'm sure he's going to do
that I I have no doubt
and just finally
and perhaps um you could explain to
viewers on this if erdogan loses and
what can the country and those who
cannot expect from the opposition it's a
coalition of different parties is that
right
okay I cannot be cool-headed about this
I have many friends who are going to
wear belly dancer costumes and dance in
in central Istanbul men and women
so it will be a big holiday a national
holiday for sure at least for half of
the country but they have been waiting
for this quite a long time so it will be
such a relief you have an expression in
Turkish
uh you know as if the ox that's sitting
on my chest has just got up I think the
feeling will be like that you know
finally we're going to breathe in terms
of reality politics uh well I mean like
I think what a Brazilian social media
user uh said when bolsonaro lost goes
for turkey as well we know that it's
going not going to be heaven but at
least we will know that the doors of the
hell will be closed
uh and that's such a relief that is such
a that will be such a relief hopefully
[Music]